Hi,
so I wanted to discuss this new requirement with you about the web
analytics integration
Yep. Yeah.
so web analytics integration.
Previously someone did a piece of work
and I'll have to dig that out.
They created a GA account for us which is
free to create and use.
What we need to do is add a little bit of
JavaScript snippet that GA provides.
Into every single page and then it starts
tracking just the general analytics page
view analytics.
It won't have any detail of what kind of
savings people are interacting with or
any data about the users or the kind of
users access.
It it'll be generic at this point,
but I think that's fine as a first action
we can in a future release we can do a
more.
We can look at sending some additional
data to analytics.
OK, so.
So basically what we're saying is there
is a Google Analytics integration code
snippets somewhere and the developer
needs to go and add it to all the pages.
Yeah.
Of the website,
are the number of pages like fairly straightforward to identify?
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be. I think it should be,
yeah,
it should be a template or something that
we can update, not.
OK.
We probably don't have to go into every
page maybe and we just update the
template and that applies to all the
pages or maybe a couple of templates that
we need to update.
OK,
so it's already template driven the
design at the moment.
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be.
OK.
So I will need to provide a little dig it
out where the snippet is.
Otherwise I might create a new one and
share it.
OK.
So assign the ticket to to me or I don't
know how we want to do it.
Yeah, yeah,
I'll create the ticket and I'll assign it
to you then.
OK.
Cool.
OK, OK, cool. Short and sweet.